[Music]
teacher's pet is based on the Disney
show that ran in the early 2000 starring
Nathan Lane I didn't even know it
existed but apparently it was popular
enough to make a movie that apparently
bombed at the box office and I can kind
of see why not to say the movie is bad I
actually don't think it is but uh-huh
ma'am water shrimp it opens with a dog
named spot voice by nathan lane who
lives with a boy named Leonard and
apparently he's smart enough to go to
school so he disguises himself as a boy
to go and educate himself and have all
sorts of fun but the problem is spot
actually does want to be a boy bus he
hears about a doctor voiced by Kelsey
Grammer who's conducting experiments to
turn animals into people Spock is
excited and convinces Leonard and his
mother to go on a road trip to take him
there seeing how school's out and every
one of these Disney TV shows turn in the
movies always seems to open with school
being out and they try themselves all
the way down to Florida but to a spots
friends do more research and find out
that the experiments don't work and thus
they've rushed down there as quickly as
possible to let him know but the
experiment has already happened and it
seems to be a success but there's only
one problem in dog years but isn't a boy
he's a man so now he has to walk around
as a human man trying to be a human man
yeah this is really really odd I guess
the story is kind of general little kid
TV show movie stuff but the attitude
pacing and humor is beyond bizarre the
design of the characters I describe as
beautifully ugly there isn't one
good-looking character in this but at
the same time it's kind of fun how weird
and distorted they look I swear they're
done by the same person who did the
airborne designs the humor seems to
match it I can't really say it's cynical
I can't really say it's optimistic it's
just energized strange constantly
yelling constantly getting your face
constantly throwing everything they can
at you for the most part it is kind of
entertaining the style of humor is so in
its own world it's kind of hard not to
get sucked into it and want to have fun
right along with them the doctor for
example gets so excited at one point he
just rips his head off yeah that's just
something that can happen in
world people can fall to pieces or
explode or their skin can rip apart from
their body but a split second later
they're back to normal it's kind of
typical cartoon stuff but the more I
think about it I don't see that much
typical cartoon stuff in movies we never
got a run in Stimpy big screen movie we
never got a Tiny Toons big screen movie
the typical cartoony slapstick stuff we
don't usually see in theaters at least
not to this extent on the one hand it's
kind of nice I don't always know where
it's going I don't always know what kind
of joke is coming next most Disney films
have what four to five songs in them
this one has something like 10 to 15
every other second they're singing and
they're just throwing their all into it
just every single moment they're trying
to do something crazy the one downside
is it can get old after a while
the film doesn't take that many breaks
from it's weird kooky sense of humor
when it does there's not a ton of
emotion to keep you interested because
of that I can see this film very easily
annoying some people for me it was
alright but even I'll admit I was trying
to get a little tired of it thankfully
the humor for me was so energized and
weird I didn't mind too much but I can
see people getting really sick of it
really fast nothing about it seems
particularly cinematic it just seems
like a really long cartoon but some
people want to see really long cartoons
I love cartoons and so I kind of like
this it's weird shapes and colors mixed
with weird ideas and characters I can't
help it I thought it was bizarrely kind
of fun did it get grating sometimes once
in a while but at the same time I had to
give him credit for just going all the
way it never lets up it's always trying
to do something insane and I guess the
kind of insane part of me really
appreciates it it's still smart it's
still well-thought-out just because it's
silly doesn't mean it's not done by
people who are extremely talented
I guess fans of the show will really
enjoy it I mean I have to assume the
show was just as crazy to any newcomers
though just keep in mind it is pretty
relentless it just constantly throws
crazy thing after crazy thing with
somehow a kid related moral attached to
it to some that can definitely be a
turn-off but for me it's the right
amount of madness for a solid view
you